all right busy night tonight welcome to
hannity the left is getting
very desperate and breaking tonight new
york's liberal attorney general trying
to dissolve the national rifle
association with a new lawsuit
really just 89 days before the election
sounds like weird timing to me so is the
state of new york using taxpayer money
to interfere
in the 2020 election why now and we'll
explain
i think there are other priorities the
state should be concerned about like
safety and the lives of its citizens
we'll investigate that
also this madness along with the left's
conspiracy theories their hysteria
their usual slander all ratcheting up
because democrats have nothing positive
to run on
and this is now a fact joe biden is a
disaster
he looks real he looks extremely weak
even
from his basement bunker with the
lightest
possible schedule of any presidential
candidate
in history he is struggling and
struggling big time
what a whopper day we'll call today he's
really not even campaigning he's just
you know poking his head up for an hour
or two out of the comfort of his own
home
and yet he cannot hold it together so
far this week
has been an unmitigated disaster it
started yesterday when biden had
this weird strange embarrassing public
breakdown
while touting his cognitive fitness see
if you can understand this
pay very close attention to the words
fitness at the end of this
but please clarify specifically have you
taken
a cognitive no i haven't taken the test
why the hell would i take a test
come on man that's like saying you
before you got in this program if you
take a test where you're taking cocaine
or not what do you think huh
are you what do you say to president
trump
who brags about his test and makes your
mental state
an issue for voters well
if he can't figure out the difference
between an elephant and a lion
i don't know what the hell he's talking
about did you watch that look come on
man
i i know you're trying to goad me but i
mean
i'm so forward looking to have an
opportunity to sit with the president
or stand with the president and debates
there can be plenty of time
and by the way as i joke with them you
know
i i shouldn't say it i'm going to say
something i don't i i probably shouldn't
say
anyway i am uh i am very
willing to let the american public judge
my physical mental
my physical as well as my mental fitness
and uh to uh you know to make a judgment
about
who i am come on man
we need bumper stickers and t-shirts uh
let's see you'd get tested for cocaine
are you a junkie come on man loses his
train of thought
three times in a minute i don't know
what the hell he's talking about an
elephant in a line did he mean an
elephant and a nanky
meaning you know what does he mean here
um
this is just you know the beginning of
his bad week
why is he having such a hard time saying
i can look forward to the fitness now he
if he really means that well we can have
the extra debate that donald trump has
called for before
anybody votes before early voting starts
that is fair for the american people let
the american people decide joe
says he's looking forward to it okay
game on joe
do it before a single vote is cast
can't say the word fitness and by the
way just a short time ago
just a matter of fact he said of course
i had a cognitive
exam i'm tested constantly
okay when he's out of the basement
bunker he doesn't know sometimes what
cities he
he's in he doesn't know what office he's
running for at times
he doesn't remember or doesn't seem to
remember that we are endowed by our
oh the thing you know the the the thing
joe the answer is god the creator of
everything
if you forget give me a call i'll help
you out in the middle of the debate we
can cheat nobody will know
now he can't tell his wife from his
sister at one time and
so we'll use his words come on man i
don't know what the hell he's saying
what's going on here a democrats refused
to talk about in public
the mob in the media they're not talking
about it in public
but i can tell you i know for a fact in
private
they're telling me and many other people
they know it is a
serious problem they can't put their
head in the sand forever
like an ostrich like it or not biden's
cognitive abilities
are extremely troubling and they will be
on the ballot
and what we're seeing frankly is just
bizarre
it's not normal that's all i know i look
at a frail guy
that if he ever had a slow pitch seems
to be gone
and we witnessed today yet another
disaster for biden
during a virtual event with the national
association of black journalists
national association of
hispanic journalists biden suggested
that african americans
are all the same what
you know remember first we heard you
ain't black
now this take a look unlike the
african-american community with notable
exceptions
the latino community is an incredibly
diverse community
with incredibly different attitudes
about different things
okay we'll let you decide pretty much a
terrible thing to say
judgment broad sweeping generalization
earlier president trump he responded
calling biden's remarks a great insult
to the african-american community take a
look
joe biden this morning totally
disparaged and
insulted the black community what he
said is incredible
and i don't know what's going on with
him but
it was a very insulting statement he
made it was a great insult to the black
community
and for the record it was donald trump
to put criminal
justice reform he's the one that did it
not barack no
not joe police reform that's trump not
barack and not joe
funding for the largest amount of money
in the longest commitment of time
historically black colleges that was
donald trump that was not barack and it
wasn't joe
and by the way record after record after
record low unemployment for every
demographic in this country including
african americans and hispanic americans
yeah that was donald trump uh biden and
obama
gave us 13 million more americans on
food stamps
after eight years and eight million more
in poverty in the lowest labor
participation rate since the 70s
worst recovery since the 40s president's
right
and by the way can you imagine the
hysteria on the left
if it was trump who made those horrible
remarks keep in mind
this is not an isolated incident for the
ever forgetful and corrupt joe
his track record on race is atrocious
his close personal mentor as he said
the person he praised was yeah the
former klansman robert kkk
byrd the guy that filibustered the civil
rights act of 64 opposed the voting
rights act to 65.
lyndon johnson relied on 80 republicans
in the house and senate to pass that
not a lot of democrats al gore's father
he wasn't there
when when history mattered imagine if
donald trump praised the former clan
leader who
in fact filibustered the civil rights
act in the 70s biden actively working
with desegregationists
why to slow school integration let's go
to nbc news shall we
he led the charge on an issue that kept
black students away from the classrooms
of white students and according to the
washington post
biden spoke out repeatedly and
forcefully against sending white
children to majority black schools and
black children to majority white schools
1977 biden worried that his children
that happened would grow up in a racial
jungle a few years later biden lied
about marching in the civil rights
movement
he also lied about endorsements from the
naacp
1993 he's the guy that referred to
city inner city youth as predators on
our streets
2006 he's the guy that told the crowd
well you have to have a slight indian
excerpt
to work at a 7-eleven or a dunkin donuts
quote i'm not kidding
2006 he bragged that his state was a
slave
state 2007 he's the guy that said
this is the key word first
the first mainstream african-american
who is articulate and bright
and clean that's storybook man
come on man the man comes up a lot with
this guy anyway last year he said quote
poor kids could be
just as bright as white kids and
recently biden said quote
you ain't black if you support donald
trump and then he said of course
we're going to put you all back in
chains when you think about it
biden's track record on race is nothing
short of a disgrace
and imagine if donald trump had said all
these things
poor kids are just as bright and just as
as white kids
you cannot go to a 7-eleven
or a dunkin donuts unless you have a
slight indian accent
what kind of a chance with a
northeastern liberal like joe biden
stand
in the south better than anybody else
and you don't know my state my state was
a slave state my state is a border state
my state is the eighth largest black
population in the country you got the
first
sort of mainstream african american
who was articulate and bright and and
clean and a nice looking guy i mean it's
that's a storybook they're gonna put you
all back in chains
it's a long way until november we got
more questions
you got more questions but i tell you if
you have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or
trump and you ain't black
okay now biden were a republican if he
were donald trump he'd be ripped to
shreds
by his own democratic party in the media
mob
i've laid out the history every two and
four years how
the media divides rich versus poor old
versus young
black versus white i played that history
repeatedly
and by the way biden's statement today
about african americans was not only
the only puzzling moment from his
virtual event in one
very bizarre moment biden actually
changed his position on the filibuster
almost mid-sentence this is the same
exact virtual hearing
it's not like well he said i've been
tested i'm constantly tested i've never
been tested how dare you ask me if i'm
tested take a look
what i said was that if in fact they
are as obstreperous as is expected
we'd have to get rid of the filibuster
but the filibuster has also
saved a lot of bad things from happening
too
so you're oh yeah no no
i i i'm sorry i thought i'm on record as
saying that
if the republicans if there's no way to
move other than
getting rid of the filibuster that's
what we'll do oh biden early today made
comments about the diversity of african
and latino communities
i want to clarify no way that i mean to
suggest the african-american community
is a monolith not by identity not on
issues at all
throughout my career oh we're laying out
your career
i've witnessed diversity of thought
background sentiment
yeah okay as you can see that just came
out
is he just tweeted that out it's not
just weak because of his inability to
communicate clearly but also
he's struggling to shore up his radical
socialist
base and by the way now in order to make
them happy
he is running the most progressive
platform that's ever existed in history
and recently promised to halt all border
wall construction
if he ever becomes president he's
promised amnesty
to illegal immigrants in other words
will become the united sanctuary states
of america
he also said today that illegal
immigrants should receive subsidized
health care take a look
should undocumented immigrants also be
able to get subsidized
health care if they are
working in the united states of america
and they
are paying taxes they should have access
to health care
they should have have access to what
everybody else has access to
the most important documented worker
no it depends not all undocumented
workers are working
you say you say on every undocumented
worker
he promised amnesty just added to the
list government subsidized health care
for illegal immigrants
his 92 trillion dollar appeasement for
the green new deal is promising to spend
trillions
on aoc's plan which is madness 52
trillion dollar
doubling down on stupid obamacare
some version of medicare for all free
housing free higher education free
healthy food by the government
guaranteed free child care free paid
family leave
free vacation free free free
everything's free
now all of your needs will be taken care
of cradle to grave womb to tomb all of
your worries eliminated
and a magical socialist utopia the only
problem is
these problems are completely
unfulfillable
they're false promises the math doesn't
add up
not even on joe's you know old-fashioned
abacus
and if this radical agenda is ever
implemented your friends
and your freedoms friends guess what the
friends that love freedom
it's going to be stripped away your
wealth it'll be confiscated
your businesses will be destroyed
america as we know it
that is freedom and liberty and guess
what
capitalism will be gone there are status
these are socialist policies and they
will fail
it's been tried it has failed too many
times to count
and that is what is on the ballot in 89
days
it's all on the ballot in 89 days